Oh, sorry, sorry.
Okay, welcome to AERA English's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d', Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Alright, today's topic is about how Westerners are always on the go.
Westerners are busy, busy, busy doing something...
...and they're always in a rush...
...especially, western people are a little bit impatient and they don't like to wait for people.
So, compared to how Japanese people can wait and take their time,...
...maybe Westerners are a little bit more impatient and they're a little bit busier.
So, western people are always rushing you.
So today's Maestro Menu, I'd like to talk about some words that you can use...
...when you wanna rush somebody, okay?
Alright.
Today.
Come on, today.
And one more.
We have time?
The clock is ticking.
Clock is ticking.
Alright. So, Maestro Lines.
You still haven't gotten ready?
Come on! The movie starts at 11 o'clock today. Let's go!
Today, come on!
Okay, and...
...the report is due at the end of the week.
Come on, the clock is ticking. We gotta start working.
Come on, it's next week.
The clock is ticking.
Alright. So, I'm on the go.
Gotta go so next week, we'll be having another show so hope you enjoy it...
...and please use these words to become the native maestro.
Alright, see you later.
Bye-bye. Got to go.
See ya!